Today curator Katy Barrett shares how
one of the most famous British artists of all time
took her sketchbook into surgery,
in another story from the stores.
Why would a famous artist be sat in
an operating theatre sketching?
Barbara Hepworth's daughter was very ill in the 1940s.
She had a bone infection disease,
and was sent to a surgeon called Norman Capener,
and Norman Capener invited Barbara Hepworth
to go and draw in surgery because he
felt she must have an affinity with
looking at human body.
This sketchbook comes from a series of operations
that she saw at the London clinic that
were to do in an operation called fenestration of the ear.
And can we see the sketches?
Absolutely we can. This is amazing because it's the
only surviving sketchbook from all of
the observations that Hepworth did.
Some of them are very simple,
you can just see the head of the surgeon here,
he's looking through the equipment,
then you get on to other kinds of annotation,
so she's marking the equipment that's being used,
later on she marks colours.
She's doing these incredibly quickly,
obviously she's not allowed to change what's happening
in the surgery, she can't make them stop
when they're in a nice composition,
so she's recording what she thinks she
might want to draw later.
What makes it stand out as one of her pieces?
Ah okay, so it's interesting.
Actually this period of work is very unusual in
Barbara Hepworth's work as a whole because
she didn't tend to do figure studies.
She tended to be very abstract, but she wrote
quite a lot about these observations
that she made in the surgery.
This is actually the sketch which became
the work in the Tate, and we can see how
she's got this real interest in hands and faces.
You can see the hands and faces and the tools.
She was particularly interested in what she called
the harmony and beauty of how surgery worked together,
and she saw it as naturally making the kind of
composition that she was trying to make in her sculpture.
Also the process of doing an operation like this,
fenestration actually involves hammering
a bit of bone out of the skull,
uses a hammer and chisel, which are the kind of
tools she of course was using in sculpture.
So she was particularly interested in
those kind of parities between surgery and art.